today we are once again celebrating 25
years of rotten tomatoes and this time
we asked you the fans to submit your top
films released in the past 25 years so
if you have a problem with this list
take it up with yourselves I'm just
kidding here are the top 10 from that
list that you submitted on ronten
tomatoes
[Music]
countdown number number 10 the Lord of
the Rings The Two Towers ending 2002 on
a high note or I guess two high notes
technically was the second film in the
trilogy after the Fellowship of the Ring
it was once again directed by Peter
Jackson and based on 1954's the two
towers the second volume of JRR Tokens
The Lord of the Rings novel among the
film storylines is the ongoing journey
of Elijah Woods Frodo and Sean ason Sam
to destroy the One Ring Of course joined
by the mysterious Gollum in this one and
also saving the once great King Theoden
who has fallen under a deadly spell if I
go Theoden
dies you did not kill me you will not
kill
him Rohan is
mine be
on
The Two Towers was a monster hit making
nearly a billion dollars at the box
office and earning six Academy Award
nominations including best picture while
winning two for best sound editing and
of course best visual effects clearly I
mean it almost looks as good as the
iPhone 15 just
kidding number nine everything
everywhere all at once it's crazy to
think a movie that came out not too long
ago is one of the best of the last 25
years according to our fans so
everything everywhere all at once was a
breakout hit of 2022 and it was written
and directed by the Daniels Quan and
sheener who also produced the film with
the russos Anthony and Joe I mean talk
about a brother Bromance the Sci-Fi
Action Adventure follows a Chinese
American immigrant played by Michelle yo
who while being audited by the IRS
basically discovers that she can save
the world by connecting with parallel
universe versions of herself and who
knew that a movie like this could put
hot dogs on the
map
[Music]
she appears to be in a universe where
everyone has hot dogs instead of fingers
I mean it just doesn't matter how many
times I see it I'm just
so evolutionary branch in the anatomy of
the human race do you think they eat
their fingers in that Universe when
they're hungry okay I know that was a
little weird let me ring it in so the
Daniels had an idea for a multi-universe
related idea as far back as 2010 and
they finally started writing it in 2016
with the lead role originally written
for Jackie Chan but good thing that it
was reworked because Michelle yo went on
to win a Best Actress Oscar for her
performance one of seven Oscar wins in
total for this movie and she's just one
of the many reasons this one carries an
86% audience score with people loving
not only the acting but the stunning
visuals and deep powerful Story 2 and of
course hot dog fingers
number eight
parasite I still cannot get over how
compelling this film is this
sociopolitical satire from South Korean
director bong junho is about a poor
family who schemes to become employed by
a wealthy family by posing as unrelated
highly qualified individuals as things
escalate we and the unsuspecting family
learned that there's much more under the
surface like literally in their hidden
basement
[Music]
for Bon ho had actually been a tutor for
for a wealthy family in Soul in his
early 20s and when a friend encouraged
him to write a play while he was working
on the film Snowpiercer he actually
leaned on those past experiences here's
hoping his were a little less dramatic
parasite did so well at the box office
and won four Oscars including best
picture best director and best original
screenplay becoming the first ever
non-english language film to win best
picture I mean this thing was is
historic and while I may be obviously a
bit obsessed I will say that watching
this one again is never a bad idea
number seven the Lord of the Rings The
Fellowship of the Ring let's go back to
Middle Earth because you guys clearly
love it there so this first installment
in The Lord of the Rings film Trilogy
arrived in December of 2001 bringing
with it all kinds of longlasting things
into pop culture you know like Hobbits
and a certain now famous movie line dark
five will never Veil you flame
of
go back to the
[Music]
shadow you shall not
pass I always use that line when someone
tries to make conversation with me in
the buffet line I'll let you guys keep
that one in your back pocket the film
gross nearly 9 $900 million worldwide
and this is 2001 we're talking about so
it became the fifth highest grossing
film ever at the time and despite a
nearly 3-hour run time it still holds a
95% audience score with viewers I mean
talk about a crowd
pleaser number six The
Matrix the movie that made us all
believe that we are basically in a
simulation to this day starring the
national treasure that is can Reeves as
a computer hacker named Neo who uncovers
in evil cyber intelligence this
cyberpunk sci-fi flick turned out to be
a cultural phenomenon for so many
reasons one of which being that it's
just a trip do not try and bend the
spoon that's
impossible instead only try to realize
the truth what truth there is no
spoon there is no spoon then you'll see
that it is not the spoon that bends it
is only yourself
[Music]
I mean I still think about this scene
when I'm holding a spoon or drinking
soup The Matrix was written and directed
by the wowski Lana and Lily who also
wrote and directed the 2003 sequels The
Matrix Reloaded and The Matrix
Revolutions their approach to action
scenes was infuenced by Japanese
animation martial arts films and Hong
Kong action Cinema considering that the
film also popularized a visual effect
known as bullet time you know the one
what a cool combination and honestly
don't even get me started on the fashion
inspiration that was and still is
inspired by this movie to this day I
mean when in doubt just thr on a black
trench coat and sunglasses guaranteed
coolness wow I cannot believe that we
are halfway there already what five
movies could possibly be better than
that let's find out
[Music]
friends number five Avengers endgame ah
the movie that was all movies this
marked the 22nd film in the MCU I mean
wow and a direct sequel to 2018s
Avengers Infinity War so in it the
Avengers that remain are trying to
reverse the actions of Thanos from that
previous film and even with the big
three Iron Man Captain America and Thor
It Ain't Easy I mean if only they were
playing a basketball game am I right
teaming with life
that knows not what it is lost but only
what it has been
[Music]
given a grateful Universe born out of
blood they'll never know
it because you won't be alive to tell
them endgame holds a 90% audience score
with over 50,000 ratings
and thanks to the audience's money it
went on to become the highest grossing
film ever at the time with almost $2.8
billion perhaps even more impressive is
that it won the golden tomato Award for
best movie wide release in 2019 what an
honor Number Four The Lord of the Rings
The Return of the King it is official
audiences love the Lord of the Rings
this threequel from 2003 includes the
final confrontation between forces of
Good and Evil which are fighting over
the future of Middle Earth and frankly
it just has some pretty gnarly bad guys
all
around you
fool no man can kill
me die
[Music]
now I am no
man Return of the King picked up 11
Oscar wins on 11 nominations including
best picture which basically tied it
with Ben her and Titanic for the most
Oscar wins ever and despite being 3
hours and 20 minutes long here it is as
one of the all-time favorite movies of
the past 25 years proving that you can
hold your pee in the theater if it's
worth
it number three
Inception I know a lot of you are
thinking alas a Nolan film if that is
you get very excited director
Christopher Nolan finally teamed up with
Leonardo DiCaprio after years of trying
to make it happen with the latter
playing a professional Thief who
basically can steal information by
infiltrating the subconscious of his
targets now along with Leo is a very
strong cast that includes Maran coard
Elliot paig Tom Hardy Killian Murphy and
our boy Joseph Gordon levit and of
course let's not forget the other star
those amazing visual
[Music]
effects
it is no wonder that when Chris first
started working on this script movies
like The Matrix number six on this list
the 13th floor and momento were
influencing the ideas Inception crushed
it at the box office with over $828
million worldwide good enough for the
fourth highest grossing film of
2010 number two Interstellar Nolan again
this film featured really big names like
Matthew mccon Anne Hathaway Matt Damon
Jessica Chastain along with some
incredible visuals and it's set in a
dystopian future where a group of
astronauts travel through a wormhole in
search of a new home for Humanity and
let's just say it's a kind of an intense
Mission BR cop you're up case blow the
cabin auction through the main thrusters
we're going to spark it Roger there
locked de press
youring
enges
up and get this an under the radar
director by the name of Steven Spielberg
maybe you've heard of him was originally
attached to the project alongside writer
Jonathan Nolan after Spielberg's
departure though it was Jonathan who
suggested bringing on his brother
Christopher Nolan to direct the film and
to give it some street cred a Caltech
theoretical physicist and Noble laua in
physics served as executive producer and
scientific consultant who also happened
to write a tie-in book called the
science of interstellar you're welcome
nerds and last but not least number one
The Dark Knight I mean that is a
Christopher Nolan triple whammy which I
am not surprised by since you guys
actually voted Nolan best director of
the last 25 years on another rt25 list
now this one is just one of a few movies
on this list that also actually popped
up on the critics picks of the past 25
years but it's worth noting that this
has the highest audience score in all of
the DCU along with Christian baale as
Batman the ensemble cast includes Gary
Oldman Michael Kane Aaron eckart Morgan
Freeman Maggie Gyllenhaal who are
sometimes pretty much all forgotten
about because of Heath Ledger's Oscar
winning performance as
Joker
a now this was the first major motion
picture to be filmed with highres IMAX
cameras I mean no wonder so many people
saw it in theaters and of course Nolan
preferred to use practical effects over
CGI whenever possible it all added up to
the highest grossing film of the year
with over a billion dollars earned eight
Oscar Noms with the win for best sound
editing and selection for the national
film registry as just the second
superhero film after 1978's Superman I
think we can all agree that the Dark
Knight is number one in our hearts well
friends that is our list list thank you
for helping us put it together and for
celebrating 25 years of Rotten Tomatoes
we couldn't have done it without you I
mean truly though we wouldn't even have
had this list so thank you for more on
all these movies that we discussed today
be sure to hit up rot tomatoes.com and
our very special rt25 section thanks for
checking out today's list until next
time I am your host Nas Perez and we'll
see you back here for more Rotten
Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]
w